today on the matt walsh show the state
of michigan has expanded its mass
mandates to include children who are two
three and four years old we become a
society of adults who fear breathing
fresh air and we're raising our kids to
share in that phobias we'll talk about
that today also five headlines including
a totally predictable crisis
as police departments across the country
struggle to find new recruits i wonder
why and lindsey graham gets in trouble
for saying that obama's election proves
systemic racism isn't real
but isn't he correct about that our
daily cancellation we'll talk about the
man who was doxed and then fired from
his job for allegedly harassing a dude
in a prom dress but as always with these
things there's a whole lot more to the
story and we'll talk about that and a
lot more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
i think it was sometime in july or
august when i first personally noticed
the shift i've been traveling all
throughout this past year
living my life basically as normal the
entire time in the first few months of
the pandemic when i went went out in
public and especially on planes
i would see people fidgeting constantly
with their masks pulling them down under
their nose
taking them off whenever they could
i did the same i still do the same
whenever i'm in a situation where i have
no choice but to wear one like on an
airplane
but uh you know the tactic one one
classic tactic now for me anyway is uh
you
they say you could take the mask off to
drink a bottle of water so just have a
bottle of water in your hand maybe it
takes you a lot maybe it takes you the
entire flight to drink it who knows
but sometime in the summer
i noticed that most people
had stopped doing this
they'd put the mask on
keep it on without a break
i flew across the country several times
five or six hour flights
and everyone around me kept the mask on
over the nose without messing with it
for the whole trip
even keeping it on to eat as i've
complained about simply lifting the mask
inserting a pretzel or peanut one at a
time
now i guess we're supposed to see this
as a positive change
but i found it deeply
disturbing it seemed to me that that
people had gone from wearing the mask
begrudgingly
to wearing it because they wanted to and
liked it
it didn't want to be without it
there was a psychological shift in a lot
of people
and not a good one
we say whatever you want about masks
we shouldn't like them
you shouldn't like wearing a mask we
shouldn't want to cover our faces in
public
we shouldn't prefer the mask over fresh
air or even recycled air on an airplane
this psychological shift is why masking
may never go away in many corners of
society even in situations
where they're effectively pointless for
example vaccinated people are required
in most situations still to wear masks
even though the cdc itself says that
point that only
.008 percent
.008 percent of fully vaccinated people
have had breakthrough cases of the virus
that's the cdc's data
only one percent of those of the .008
have died so that puts your chance of
dying from the virus if you've been
vaccinated according to the cdc's data
at if my math is right and a lot of
times it isn't
point zero zero zero one percent
and yet vaccinated people not only have
to wear the mask
but many seem perfectly eager and
willing to do so they want to
the mask for them serves no medical
purpose
it serves a psychological purpose it
fills an emotional need
and it's a very disorder deranged
unnatural need it satiates a fear
a fear of error
there are people in this country lots of
people
who after the sustained psychological
terror campaign from the media and
health experts quote unquote like fauci
are now afraid of the air
now speaking of the air
study after study shows that your chance
of getting the virus outside we we read
from the latest study on this front
yesterday
um your chance of getting the virus
outside especially from simply walking
past someone briefly is from a
statistical standpoint
nearly non-existent
it's as close to non-existent as a
chance can be but the fact that it's not
entirely non-existent the fact that
there is a chance
however slim however vanishing
a theoretical chance is too much for
some people to bear
they've been broken
their minds have been damaged
and nowhere is that more evident than
with our approach to children
as the cdc announced the guidelines for
summer camps calling for children and
vaccinated adults to wear masks at all
times including outside
the state of michigan imposed its own
psychotic mandates or rather added to
the psychotic mandates already in place
the state has declared
that its mask mandate is being brought
in to include two to four-year-olds
so children from the age of two
must wear masks now in michigan
everywhere in all public places
including outside
here's a local news report about the
policy let's watch
any parent who's ever had a child that
age understands how challenging it can
be to get them to comply with well
anything sometimes for many parents the
notion of getting toddlers to wear face
masks for hours on end seem utterly
impossible well i spoke with the
president of the michigan chapter of the
american academy of pediatrics and he
says it is not only possible but needed
even though data shows there is only a
small amount of covet spread in schools
and day cares experts believe we need to
do everything we can to improve our
numbers here in fact the cdc has long
suggested that people age two and older
wear masks however some are concerned
that teachers and daycare providers will
have to spend too much time focused on
keeping those masks on those kids faces
and too little time on normal routines
again this kind of goes back to if we're
modeling good behavior and talking to
them about it
you know taking away that kind of dogma
or stigma
um of of it being bad
then they're more likely to wear it so
put it on their stuffed animals show you
know pictures of other kids wearing it
um you know and as they get older
they're obviously going to ask more
questions and you can be able to explain
you know like you're wearing this to
you know help protect yourself and to
help protect others and and you know
kind of doing your part and to kind of
get through this pandemic
put it on your their stuffed animal
if you do that
as a parent
you are a lunatic
and that guy you just heard from there
that's
i'm not even sure who that guy is
we're living under a tyranny of guys
like that
dudes like that
have been given have been given
incomprehensible power over our lives
and over our children
he's worried that there will be a stigma
we don't want to have a stigma around
masks there should be a stigma
okay it is bad
it is bad to put masks on
three-year-olds for hours on end or for
any length of time it is bad it's
shameful it's disgraceful it's abusive
we know that children are not and have
never been at any serious risk to
contract or spread covet the people
supporting and imposing these mandates
admit that openly
there is no articulable and reasonable
medical case for putting a a muzzle on a
small child whatever minuscule risk it
supposedly avoids is far far outweighed
by the cost and there is a cost
a steep one
first you don't need to be a doctor to
apply common sense to this
masks are going to restrict airflow
they're over your face
they weren't made to be worn as everyday
items by everyone including children
including during physical exercise and
play
and on top of the breathing problem it's
also unhygienic kids are dirty kids are
kind of gross frankly young kids
will wipe their noses with their shirts
they'll pee in their pants it's a mess
what kind of condition
do you think that mask will be in by the
end of the day
that thing that's been attached to their
face that thing they've been breathing
through for seven hours
but the brainless sheep among us will
simply shrug their shoulders and say you
know there's no way for us to know if
it's unhealthy to have young kids
breathing through a dirt and snot and
crusted rag all day
well we can't we can't possibly know
until someone with public health expert
in their title tells us the sheep will
say
as they get back to munching on the
grass
but the physical risk as dire as it is
must be considered secondary in my mind
to the psychological risk
we know that many adults are now afraid
of the air afraid to walk down the
street without a surgical mask
mary many adults carry on like they're
living downwind of chernobyl
how do you think our kids feel
well not our kids my own kids the older
ones understand that masking is a silly
thing
that they have to do on occasion if we
need to bring them into a store or
something where it's required
and i've told them this it's silly it's
dumb we gotta do it just because we
gotta run into the store real quick
um
my youngest almost two doesn't think
anything about masks and has never worn
one and will not wear one
but many other kids in this country
kids whose parents have broken brains
are being raised to share in their
parents fear of the air
we are raising a generation of children
to fear walking down the street
children who think that you know they
might get sick and die if they play on
the monkey bars without a piece of cloth
covering their face
it's hard to even predict the long-term
effects because no society on earth has
ever done anything quite like this
we are running a psychological
experiment on our kids
and on ourselves
that's what this masking mandate stuff
is
and the results of that experiment are
already horrifying
and i'm afraid we'll only get worse
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now we check in with our friends at
legacy box and it's a good time to uh
think about legacy box because you know
mother's day is right around the corner
and you better be thinking about don't
leave it for the last minute get
yourself in trouble uh you don't want to
do that think about what you want to get
from mother's day and legacy box is the
perfect mother's day gift legacy box is
a super simple mail-in service to have
all of your video tapes camcorder tapes
film reels um pictures anything that you
have digitally preserved on a thumb
drive dvd or the cloud
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably preserve your past those
of us who are ancient like myself you
know we grew up in a time
before
you know you had digital cameras before
everything was already digitized which
means we've got a lot of our memories
our childhood everything on these
antiquated technologies so don't let it
just sit there in a box don't let it get
destroyed you got to take care of it
that's what legacy box is all about the
process is so easy from start to finish
you pack and send all that stuff their
team digitizes everything by hand and
they send it back to you and you enjoy
or your mother enjoys if you're setting
this as a mother's day gift for a
limited time legacy box is running a 50
off mother's day special order your
legacy box today to take advantage of
this incredible offer this is one of the
best discounts they've ever offered
legacy box is perfect for you or for
someone you love go to legacybox.com
walsh and say 50 while supplies left us
last that's
legacybox.com walsh
so here's a shock you're not going to
believe this number one here from the
blaze it says following the defund the
police movement and the abolish the
police movement
constant negative coverage of law
enforcement by the media anti-police
sentiment become becoming mainstream and
the threat of riots have contributed to
a police shortage across the country
the philadelphia police department
currently has 268 vacancies and is
expecting even more shortages in the
near future
neighboring new jersey is facing a
recruiting crisis according to pat
colligan president of the new jersey
state policeman's benevolent association
uh colligan said that recent notorious
police-involved deaths of citizens such
as george floyd tamir rice and brianna
taylor have impacted recruiting efforts
um
collagen also said the quality has
really diminished in the last few years
and you know in terms of the police
officers colonel patrick callahan said
the state's largest police agency
received a historically low number of
applications this year in some years
the new jersey state police would
usually receive between fifteen thousand
and twenty thousand
listen to this this year they've
received two thousand
qualified applications
from fifteen to twenty thousand to two
thousand
in fact we have a local news report here
from um philadelphia talking about their
situation was it which is especially
dire let's listen to that
local fop president john mcnesby says
it's kind of like a perfect storm
developing the eye of the storm
revolving around several issues
including a dramatic rise in the number
of philadelphia police officers filing
for retirement a diminishing pool of
young people who even want to be a big
city cop and the suspension of new
officer training because of the pandemic
under normal circumstances there would
be dozens of new recruits coming in for
training every three months but the most
recent class graduated last december and
the next one isn't even expected to
begin until next month you got to
remember too that once you go into the
academy takes you about 10 months to
finish
so we're not looking at putting any
boots on the ground until maybe next
spring then you throw in the recent
changes to the department's residency
rules mandating all police trainees live
in philadelphia before they enter the
academy nobody's going to move to
philadelphia hoping that they get a job
they want to make sure that they secure
employment and then move in richard
vonna director of the bucks county
police training center says all of these
issues are also inspiring younger
officers from the city to seek
employment in the suburbs and not just
from philadelphia
yeah you think
i mean
the problem it's it's twofold that
they're
you're gonna have a lot fewer as we're
hearing
applicants and right now we've only
talked about philly in new jersey this
is the case everywhere
um
and the applicants you do have
are going to get are going to be worse
so you're going to have fewer fewer
police and the ones that you have are
going to be worse in terms of of of
quality and and their
you know qualifications and skill level
because i think
a lot of
people who would make great police
officers and are highly qualified for it
they're going to say to themselves well
is there somewhere else where i can take
these skills maybe get into private
security something like that
why would i want to take these skills
here
where even if i do my job correctly if i
if i follow the book to a t my life
could be destroyed
this is and you know republicans
to look at the political end of this
um this is a problem that republicans
could be trying to address could be
speaking to because it's a very very
serious problem
and cities across the country are
dealing with the effects of it
and that's only going to get worse
because it turns out that yeah you you
despite what the abolish the police
idiots have to say
and of course the people
you know the the most prominent
cheerleaders of that movement
members of the squad and so forth uh
they're doing they're all well off
they're doing perfectly fine they're in
safe neighborhoods
they've they've got security they've got
all that kind of stuff
you know when they go to their job
they're surrounded by armed men
protecting them
but just the average people your average
american living in a city
they're going to feel the effects of
that because it turns out you need
police officers
you do
if you have laws
then you need people to enforce them
and right now the people who are making
the laws
are doing everything they can to
undermine and attack
the people tasked with enforcing the
laws that they made
just think about that for a second
it's the legislative branch of the
government
people in congress
maxine waters and every all the other
democrats
who are the ones leading the charge
against the police
but they're also the ones making the
laws
that the police have to enforce
um
so that's you know that's that's what's
gonna happen you have more more people
say of course what's what's what's the
point why why do i want to get into this
line of work and republicans so
republicans they could be speaking to
this
but instead you have republicans lining
up behind oh yeah we need police reform
that's what we need
now republicans talking about ending
qualified immunity
this is becoming a popular talking point
obviously on the left but even on the
rights
and so what does that mean you end
qualified immunity i'll tell you that
you get rid of qualified immunity and
you're just we're not gonna have any
cops
all the cops are leaving
because what that means is that every if
you're a cop every
person you try to arrest
anyone you have to tackle to the ground
in the process of trying to arrest them
they can sue you now they can sue you
personally
every single person you encounter try to
arrest them maybe you um you know you
put the handcuffs on it makes their
wrists a little sore now they can sue
you they can sue you personally
so if you want a recipe for having zero
cops that's the way to do it
and of course idiot republicans you know
they
rather than addressing that issue there
yeah we need police reform
no police reform is is not what we need
right now
that's not the problem
there's there's a lot of reform needed
in our cities and it's not to the police
first and foremost
all right number two tulsi gabbard
posted a video which i i want to play
this for you
just because
she she says a lot of things in this
video that up until about five years ago
would have been totally uncontroversial
and cliched
if you had heard this video
five years ago you would you would just
yawn and say yeah well of course that's
what all politicians say
but now this is edgy and controversial
uh here she is let's listen
my dear friends my fellow americans
please please let us stop the
racialization of everyone and everything
it's racialism
we are all children of god and are
therefore family in the truest sense
no matter our race or ethnicity
this is aloha
and this is what our country and the
world need
the mainstream propaganda media and
politicians they want us to constantly
focus on our skin color and the skin
color of others because it helps them
politically or financially
aloha means respect and love for others
it's what enables us to see beyond our
skin color and see the soul the person
within
so let's do our best to cultivate this
aloha in our hearts
and see and treat others through this
prism of love
not through the prism of race and
ethnicity
please let us not allow ourselves to be
led down this dark and divisive path
of racialism
and hate
where have we fallen to as a society
that
what you just heard there is
controversial
it should be totally cliche it should
require no political courage at all to
say that
what's she saying she's saying
let's all be one happy family you know
we're all we're all americans let's try
to get along
that's our message
but these days that's um
that's that's edgy right there what you
just heard
so is this from lindsey graham he got
into some trouble for for this answer
about he was on uh fox news sunday was
asked about
systemic racism uh and kind of
impressively when he was when he was
asked whether systemic racism exists he
said no
and this was the reason he gave
senator is there systemic racism in this
country in policing
and in other institutions
no not in my opinion we just elected a
two-term african-american president the
vice president is of african-american
indian descent so our systems are not
racist america is not a racist country
within every society you have bad actors
pretty reasonable answer
there's there's a lot of statistical
evidence that systemic racism
against black people in this country
in modern society is a myth
um
especially the claim that systemic
racism in in policing there's there's a
lot of statistical evidence which we've
talked about all the time on the show
that that's a myth but what lindsey
graham points to perfectly reasonable
if our if our systems are designed to
oppress black people
and to keep them oppressed and keep them
poor and so on and so forth
then
how is it that a black man managed to
become president twice
these are
if this is if this is systemic racism
it's pretty ineffective
this is the most incompetent systemic
racism we've ever seen
that a black man managed to get to the
top of the system
he was at the head of the system
does that in and of itself by itself uh
prove that systemic racism against black
people in modern america is false
not really but it's it's
to prove it you can look to all the
other statistical evidence but um
it's pretty good
evidence
against that proposition
at least it's something that you would
have to if if you are
maintaining the theory that there are
systemic racism against black people
then
a black president is something that
doesn't really fit into that theory
and so you have to explain it
offer some kind of explanation
how did that happen if there's systemic
racism against black people
but but but the the people on the left
um
who propagate this theory
rather than explaining it what they'll
do is they'll simply laugh at you and
scoff at you if you bring this up
it's the same thing with um
when someone
says oh you know i'm not racist i have
black friends
and we're told that that's a really
stupid excuse that doesn't prove
anything that's that's so dumb
well no i mean it is pretty good
evidence actually that a person isn't
racist
you would think if somebody was racist
against a particular race they probably
wouldn't have friends in that race
that's at least that's not what you
would expect of a racist person
but that's another one where
no one ever tries to deal with that they
they simply laugh at it and and insist
that that's a bad excuse they don't
explain why it's a bad excuse
all right number three levar burton
who's the dude from reading rainbow uh
for some reason was being interviewed by
the view i don't know why
and that's that's what led to him being
asked about cancel culture
especially as it pertains to books like
uh dr seuss he's a guy who's read many
of dr seuss book to to children during
his reading rainbow days
and here's what he had to say about
cancer he says it's not cancelled
culture it's consequence culture and
it's actually a very wonderful lovely
thing here's what he says
i think we need to put things in
perspective um in terms of cancer
culture i i
i think it's misnamed that's a misnomer
i think we have a consequence culture um
and that consequences are finally
encompassing everybody in the society
whereas um
they haven't been
ever in this country
so um i think i think that there there
are good signs that are happening in the
culture right now and i think it has
everything to do with a new awareness on
people who were simply unaware of the
real nature of life in this country for
people who have been othered since this
nation began
consequence culture yeah because when
you think of our culture
right that's what you think culture
where people are held accountable
a culture of mature adults who
understand there are consequences for
their actions is that what you think
the the problem is precisely that the
consequences are not the same for
everyone
that's that's what canceled culture is
that's the point
it is wielded as a political cudgel
and it's not the same for everyone not
everyone is held to the same standard
and it's not enough to simply say oh
it's a consequence
you do this people don't like it there's
a consequence
well shouldn't we talk about what the
consequence is or ought to be
yeah if you want to if you want to say
that cancer culture is a consequence you
know you do something or say something
and then the mob comes after you and
tries to destroy your life
uh you lose your job and everything
we'll talk about a case of this the most
recent case we'll talk about in the
daily cancellation coming up
but yeah that's that's a consequence
sure
in a certain sense
but is it a proportional consequence
is it a fair consequence
because the consequence right now is
that if you have
um
an opinion
you know or or if you if you share a
perspective
that's outside of the mainstream the
consequence can be that your whole life
is road
sure it's a consequence culture
may be called disproportionate
consequence culture unjust consequence
culture
unequally unevenly applied consequence
culture i'll go with any of those
and as i said we've got a great example
of this um
coming up in in just a minute we get to
the daily cancellation all right here's
a story out of
oklahoma city
really important story so we're going to
play this for you about a fugitive who
um
has finally been found after years on
the lamb
really harrowing stuff here let's watch
first thing she told me was felony
embezzlement so i thought i was going to
have a heart attack it was a moment of
disbelief for karen mcbride as she was
talking to the cleveland county district
attorney's office this week where she
learned she was a wanted felon for never
returning
sabrina the teenage witch on vhs 21
years ago
a movie she says she never even rented
no actually i had lived with the young
man this was over 20 years ago he had
two
kids daughters that were eight 10 11
years old and i'm thinking he went and
got it
and didn't take it back or something i
don't know i have never watched that
show in my entire life just not my cup
of tea
online documents show mcbride was
charged with embezzlement in march of
2000 but never knew about the charges
until recently when trying to change her
name on her license after getting
married they told me that
i had a issue in oklahoma and this was
the reference number for me to call this
number and i did
meanwhile i'm a wanted felon
for a vhs tape
documents show the movie was rented at
movie place in norman oklahoma we've
since learned that business closed in
2008. so there you see uh first of all
what kind of video rental place why is
the it says sabrina the teenage witch
it's written it's like handwritten
it looks like this was
it was someone recorded it it was back
in the day the kids don't know that but
back in the day
we didn't have uh you know you didn't
have netflix on demand
dv
and then and then wrote on the tape so
bring the teenage witch and then they
rented it at a video rental place
but now that place is out of business
whose fault is that
think about it
you're stealing all these movies
you you could think of this as a you
might claim this is a victimless crime
and that's why apparently um this
felon's the charges against this felon
have been dropped which i think is
unjust remember this is consequence
culture there's consequences to this
but before you think this is a
victimless crime i can remember
you know
1995 96
when i was a kid
going to the video rental place
i wanted to rent um mortal kombat
there were no copies in stock
i came back every day to get a copy of
mortal kombat but people weren't
bringing them back
and so by the time i finally watched
mortal kombat all my friends had seen it
they spoiled all the good parts so this
is not a victimless crime in my opinion
consequences
all right let's move to reading the uh
the youtube comments
um william baker says matt i'm on a
family vacation and convinced my family
to watch you this week please don't
embarrass me well it's probably too late
for that william but also
can i i would never tell anyone not to
watch the show but you're on a you're on
a vacation
we talk about some pretty heavy stuff
here this is this is not how i i
wouldn't be spending a vacation watching
me talk about these kinds of issues
far be it for me to tell you not to
um
jared says i thought you were joking
about the my octopus teacher documentary
but that actually sounds interesting it
is interesting it's not everyone's cup
of tea it's a documentary about a guy
who formed a bond with an octopus so
if that sounds interesting to you then
it's uh
then go ahead and go ahead and check it
out it's also i think kurt eichenwald's
favorite documentary if you get that
joke you get it if you don't i'm not
explaining it
uh the real bridget says look at matt
it's white dad summer and i'm here for
it white dead summer that's right i was
actually trying to explain to i was
trying to explain white dad summer and
white boy summer to my wife yesterday
because she was asking me she'd been
seeing these hashtags
she's not as with it as i am and i'm not
very with it either but she was asking
me one of these hashtags about white boy
summer and i was trying to explain it
and really the whole point is that it
doesn't
it doesn't mean anything it has no point
and that's the point
um
alejandro says hey matt how long do you
think a self-described crow magnet like
you would last in a show like alone
sounds like you wouldn't mind just
fishing all day long
i love the show alone uh it's probably
our favorite show to watch my wife and i
i think i would do pretty good that's
the show where they they send these it's
like it's real survivor where they send
people out by themselves in the
wilderness they they film themselves
there's no camera crew
and uh it's just however long you could
survive whoever survives the longest
wins
i would do okay with the psychological
element of being isolated and alone
it's the survival skill part of it where
i think i might
be lacking
um
stewart says i'd love to try a matt
walsh big mac or should we call it a big
mat
well you know without context stuart
this comment seems strange on a number
of levels
but i understand what you're saying and
by the way if i if i did make my own
version of a big mac the first change
i'd make is to um use beef patties
well that are that are beef first of all
and then um
that are also thicker than a piece of
construction paper that's the that's the
that's the first change of many that i
would make personally
to the big mac
well make sure to join us tomorrow for a
special episode of backstage we'll be
watching biden's first congressional
speech i cannot tell you how excited i
am
to sit and watch it and we'll be giving
our analysis in real time as nancy
pelosi said he's expected to share his
vision for addressing the challenges of
this historic moment
so you know you don't want to miss it uh
and by it i mean our commentary i don't
expect the speech to be very
entertaining but we'll try to we'll try
to we'll try to make up for it as best
as we can it streams tomorrow at 8 30
p.m eastern 7 30 central on
dailywire.com and on our youtube channel
at uh for the daily wire so make sure
that you tune in for that also another
high energy episode of candace is coming
this friday this week candace uh hosts
political commentator and interviewer
dave rubin where they've obviously got a
lot to discuss including the recall
election of california governor gavin
newsom and his new opponent caitlyn
jenner so you some you can subscribe now
and stream candace live on fridays at 9
00 pm eastern 8 pm central only on daily
wire and if you don't have a membership
yet then go to dailywire.com subscribe
and get 25 off a new membership with
code candace now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
follow along with this story um a man
named sam johnson who happens to live
here in nashville
has become the latest victim of a
canceled culture mob that according to
the left doesn't exist
we just heard from levar burton doesn't
exist it's consequence culture but
canceled culture certainly seems real to
the people whose lives are destroyed by
it people like sam johnson
now johnson is the ceo of a company
called visual
was the ceo i should say as the media
tells it he became the subject of
national outrage and backlash and was
fired from his job and had his life
summarily ripped apart because he was
caught on camera allegedly engaged in
the quote homophobic harassment of two
gay teenagers one of whom was wearing a
prom dress now in the story the only one
we've been told the one that everyone of
course automatically assumes is totally
true and not in need of any additional
context at all in that story
johnson is the bad guy the only bad guy
and given that he's homophobic quote
unquote there is no consequence too
harsh for him
the video of this supposed harassment
went viral yesterday um
johnson's name was trending nationwide
the left was calling for his head
accounts with millions of followers put
johnson's name and personal information
out there here's a tweet from kathy
griffin for example this is what she
tweeted
with with a with the video of of of the
incident
she says if this is sam johnson in
nashville tennessee the ceo of visual
healthcare tech growth strategist
married to and then she gives his wife's
name which i won't give where they may
reside in and then she gives the town
where he lives which i won't give it
seems like he's dying to be online
famous
so no problem there just a celebrity
with 2 million followers publishing a
guy's name
his wife's name
and his town of residence all because
she's mad about a video of a dispute
between him and two other people
none of whom she knows personally
of course many headlines and major news
publications followed
many of them matter-of-factly stating
that johnson homophobically harassed a
teen boy
it didn't take very long with this kind
of pressure for his company visual to
publicly condemn him and announce that
he'd been fired
i mean they didn't even wait a day it
just took a couple hours
and they were done
of course they claim that they
investigated the situation
only took them you know a few minutes to
do it but they investigated
okay well
uh we'll play the infamous video
but before we do that i want you to hear
how this incident was framed
by the guy who did the filming
jacob geitman is his name he recorded
the altercation it was his boyfriend who
was wearing the prom dress
so here's geitman on tick tock giving
his version of events and i want to play
this first because
if you haven't seen the the video of the
incident itself
when you hear it being described
a certain image will be in your head a
certain expectation
and then when we play the actual video i
want you to see whether it lives up to
your expectations so here is geiman um
in two short videos on tick tock giving
his side of the story here it is
so tick tock has now removed the video
of my boyfriend being harassed on our
prom night two times for harassment and
bullying but i'm still gonna give you
guys a story time and i'm gonna have my
friend bree post the main video on her
tech talk account which i'll comment
below if you guys want to go and watch
it this is a long story probably gonna
have to make multiple parts but i'm in
college my boyfriend's a senior in high
school and he decided that he wanted to
wear a dress for a senior prom to kind
of break the stigma around men wearing
dresses he looked gorgeous everybody
loved it nobody had a problem with it
right we went to this hotel close to
where we lived and we got a lot of good
photos we were there for about an hour
and right as we were about to leave we
were standing outside in this little
middle area with a bunch of buildings
surrounding us this man comes up stands
about an inch behind my boyfriend and
he's like what are you wearing and he's
like a dress why
and he's like well why are you wearing
that you shouldn't be wearing that he's
like uh because i can and i want to and
i really don't give what you think so
this man starts going on and on throwing
insults at him you look disgusting you
look ridiculous you look like an idiot
men shouldn't be wearing this all of
this homophobic banter so i grabbed my
phone to start to record because i knew
i wanted to record from the get-go so i
grabbed my phone started to record he
slaps my phone out of my hand it goes
flying over on the concrete part two
coming right now part two it was getting
hot in my car so i decided to come
inside so he hits my phone out of my
hand it goes flying on the concrete i go
to grab it to start recording him again
and he tries to swing at me again which
you can see in the original video when
the camera goes out for a second you can
see him swinging he tries to hit my
phone out of my hand again but he misses
and he hits my boyfriend in the back so
that's when all of the moms that were
there they're getting really involved
out there like you need to calm down
like this is absolutely ridiculous you
were out of your mind and at this point
the hotel staff had gotten word from
inside about what was going on so two
other ladies come out and they're like
okay guys what's going on out here
he pretends like he has absolutely no
clue what's going on he's standing there
he's like i've just been standing here
the whole time i don't know what's going
on i didn't try to talk to them i didn't
hit him i didn't try to smack his phone
out of his hand i'm like dude i have a
minute long video of you harassing us
you can't just blatantly deny it like
that the staff was really great about
everything they sent him back to the bar
because he was pretty obviously drunk
just because they were calling the
police and they didn't want him to freak
out any more than he already was and as
we were leaving they told us that they
were kicking him out and calling the
police so
okay
now
based on that
you have a certain expectation for the
video of the incident you're expecting
a drunken
a pretty obviously drunken
that's what we're told
probably screaming psychopath yelling
homophobic slurs
that's how the altercation has been
described both by geitmann there in the
video and by the media and by the cancel
mob on twitter
but that's not quite what you see when
you watch it for yourself
so here is what happened as documented
uh here it is
i told that i want to wear something off
okay okay
is that right i think he looks gross
looks disgusting
yeah yeah you look like i look like
white
what
you look like
away from me what does he look like
oh dude no sir no sir i can record you
all i want
keep talking please please
look like a [ __ ] get away come on
please come on please
stop stop stop just promising
i'm sorry i'm gorgeous
are you yeah yeah just stored it right
are you okay
really worth it
okay
so there you go um now a few issues here
first of all
this video
as always picks up in the middle of a
confrontation between these people
there's quite clearly something that
preceded it
the guy filming says that sam johnson
instigated sam johnson for his part gave
a statement to newsweek saying that he
initially went over to ask the teens to
quiet down because they were being loud
obnoxious and vulgar
uh and so this wasn't initially about
the dress it had nothing to do with them
being gay he was going over because they
were being obnoxious and he was talking
about that
i don't know what really happened i
wasn't there but neither was anyone else
currently calling for sam johnson's head
on a platter which which they got they
got exactly what they wanted as always
what i do know is that in that video
the only person screaming and cursing is
the guy in the dress
i also know that the guy filming is
prompting
sam johnson literally suggesting insults
for him to say did you notice that do
you think he's disgusting do you think
he's gross
that was his words the guy filming
said it
that seems like odd behavior for an
innocent person who's supposedly being
harassed
i mean i don't know i don't know about
you but uh i've never
i can't remember the last time i was
harassed but if i ever was i wouldn't
suggest
insults for my harasser to say to me
i also know that sam johnson does not
appear drunk as was claimed
he's standing there hands in his pocket
smiling coily this is this is not the
demeanor and tone that you'd expect
based on how jacob geiman described his
behavior
i remember basically what he described
you were expecting a drunken shouting
guy shouting insults
in fact the person being harassed in
that video seems to me sam johnson's the
guy being harassed geitman is following
him around camera in his face while the
other guy screams and curses
and homophobic
the man does not say even one anti-gay
thing in that video
why is it homophobic to say that a dude
in a dress looks ridiculous
tell me exactly i want someone explain
to me exactly how that's homophobic
he does look ridiculous after all
yes
you look men in prom dresses look
ridiculous
it is objectively absurd for a guy to
wear a prom dress the dress literally
was made for girls
that's why they're it's made for girl
body parts
you're not a girl you're wearing
something that doesn't fit you wasn't
made for you it looks silly
none of that's homophobic you can
disagree
it's a disagreement over style
to call it homophobic is to claim that
all gay people wear prom dresses or like
men who wear prom dresses
which to me seems like a rather
degrading and insulting assumption
indeed we're told by the boyfriend of
the dude in the dress
that he wore it not because he liked how
it looked but because he was trying to
make a statement
he was and when you're making a
statement you're calling attention to
yourself
he was looking to break the stigma
well
if you wear something to make a
statement and call attention to yourself
you can't very well complain when you
get exactly the attention you were
hoping for
you know when the waiter brings out that
giant heaping portion of attention you
ordered you can't get offended and send
it back to the kitchen
so we have to ask ourselves
were these two guys the victim of
unprovoked harassment from a drunken
homophobic bigot
or where or were they fishing for a
reaction literally trying to prompt a
reaction even verbally prompting one and
then ready to film it and ruin the life
of whoever takes the bait
which version of events seems most
reasonable and plausible to you
or was it something in between
whatever the case
what i can say is this
this little petty exchange between a guy
named sam johnson and a guy named jacob
geithman and a guy in a dress is not
national news
nothing that happened here whatever
provoked it whoever is at fault whatever
the context
deserves to be in the headlines
even pretending that johnson was fully
to blame let's just pretend that for a
moment
pretend that he was the sole bad guy in
the situation let's pretend that
everything happened exactly as it was
described
does he deserve to have his life
destroyed over that
does that warrant outrage from millions
nationwide
does his wife deserve to be named and
shamed publicly does his family deserve
to be doxxed and harassed
i mean the answer from rational and
decent people is no obviously not
but the soulless mindless bloodthirsty
hordes who make up the cancel mob don't
really have an answer
they don't think these things through
they have the brain power and
discernment of starving vultures
they simply swoop down upon any carcass
put before them to be consumed
and yesterday sam johnson was that
carcass
and for that they not sam johnson are
today canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadosky the show is edited
by sasha tolmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nikka geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show red and purple states
gain congressional seats as blue states
lose population the anti-cop movement
continues to gain steam and we discuss
the single worst example of woke mob
targeting i've ever seen that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen
you